legends of the long night the targaryen
is used dragging about to decorate the
weapons without even knowing what the
first men used it for
[Music]
hey everybody is charlie Maisie Williams
has been doing a whole bunch of
interviews for a movie that she's
releasing with Tom Hiddleston and a
bunch of other people called early man
naturally people are asking her
questions about Game of Thrones she
talked a lot about the special combat
training that she's going to be doing so
when we saw her obtain the Valyrian
dagger during season seven we had an
idea for the larger importance that it
might play during season eight but now
we have a much better picture so let's
break this down and if you're finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos will be doing
season 8 till it drops obviously there's
a lot of book releases coming up I am
still doing a weekly giveaway for the
DVDs that I'll explain at the end of the
video so she recently said that she's
currently on her way to a night shoot
which is week 4 of 12 weeks of night
shoots like she's going back and forth
like all the actors are very busy so not
all of them are on set for the entire
duration of this shoot some of them come
and go as they need to but as you can
tell most of the stuff that they're
shooting is the big night battles like
the really big battles against the night
King then eventually whatever the final
battle is going to be in episode 5 but
she goes on to say that is just huge the
task is huge but there's no better way
to leave the show to be honest so it
makes it sound like this is going to be
most of what her character is going to
do during season 8 but that doesn't mean
that that's the only thing that she's
going to film like she's not going to
come back after that there's lots of
actors that have come and gone that
might just come back for minor scenes at
the very end because Arya is not super
high on my list of death predictions but
she just said yesterday I took a stunt
class for the new season
it's sword work combat fighting the
trainers have these big pads on so
you're allowed to just go crazy meaning
that she will be unleashed
during that third Battle of Winterfell
at some point now examining her role you
have Battle of Blackwater is a good
analog for what's happening you have
Stannis with this massive force rolling
in the Blackwater up against an
undermanned castle so it's a similar
situation with Winterfell just imagine
Stannis's forces at Blackwater times 10
like enough to literally encircle all of
Winterfell if he wanted to although I
don't think it's necessarily gonna go
down that way but there were just a
couple key moments during season 7 that
let you know what the key to defeat
the night king in his army are so there
are currently four White Walkers that we
see here in beric Dondarrion says we
don't need to kill all these whites we
just need to kill him the one that
created all of them killed him he come
two more the thing about that though is
that he is incredibly powerful and even
though they've sort of brushed over a
lot of areas training is a faceless
person they've given her some pretty
unbelievable skills but for all the
logic that they Bend I think it's a
little unbelievable to expect that Arya
will be able to immediately take down
the night king especially assuming that
he's going to stay on vissarion's back
so it's just not gonna be an easy target
but the next best thing and this is
where Arya really comes in handy is
isn't taking out these four White
Walkers because they themselves raise
squadrons of whites so you can't destroy
an entire army just by destroying these
four but Arya is an assassin this fight
proves that she's amazing in close
combat and yet she could probably rush
the field with all the rank-and-file
infantry in Dodge a lot of whites and
white walkers she could probably survive
something like that but the faster way
to take down the army would be to send
her specifically after these four white
Walker generals the real hard part is
getting her to those targets and for
everyone that's asked whether or not she
could actually wear the face of a white
Walker I don't think that that's
possible that just seems a little too
ridiculous of all the things that the TV
show has changed you just have to draw
the line at a certain point but one of
the important things about them filming
a lot of these battles at night is that
it's much easier for them to get away
with a lot of the CG that they need to
do which is where we get into dire wolf
territory the one thing that the show
has never done it really really well
portrayed dire wolves on the show like
even during season seven there are very
few scenes where Arya Stark is in the
same frame right up close with Nymeria
like they film it from different angles
they try to cut it really quickly it's
just harder for them to do during broad
daylight so at night is just much easier
to do a really cool version of that so
Nymeria in the super pack are key
towards clearing paths to these white
Walker generals for Arya for her to get
in close because that's all you need to
do just get her up real close and if she
can do this with Brienne
she could probably do this with most of
those generals now obviously I don't
think they want to make it too easy but
that's just the simplest way to
accomplish what they need to do the real
problem though is is that after you take
the first couple out they figure out
what you're trying to do and change
their tactics so we're taking this line
of thought you have to assume that by
the time they get to the last white
Walker general most of the super pack is
dead most of them are just regular
wolves Nymeria is the only dire wolf in
that pack the reason why it's called a
super pack is because she's like the
uber alpha because she's so powerful and
big but for those of you asking about
whether or not Arya's dagger is key for
killing the night king yes I do think
that it's extra special because it pops
up in Sam wells book Rhaegar had a
fondness for the prophecy he was one of
the few people in the kingdom with the
power to buy something like that the
books in the TV showed never fully
explained where Littlefinger got the
dagger from there are a lot of theories
about that but he'll precipitate the war
of the five kings by purposefully losing
the dagger to Robert Baratheon thereby
allowing it to fall into possession of
Joffrey who gave it to the cat's paw and
so on and so forth the importance of the
dagger on the TV show is mostly relative
to bran stark and those things that
happen during season one but taking it
back further than that if it appears in
Sam Wells book that means that it's
ancient
the ancient items on the show usually
have special significance
like Longclaw or heart eater Joffrey's
sword that's now in Jamie's possession
or hearts pain that's in Sam Wells
possession so what you'll probably see
like Arya Stark wielding the dagger is
the people that have Valyrian swords
that aren't fighters will give those
swords to people that are so that they
can help take out these white Walker
generals
because there's a lot of obsidian you
can give that to all sorts of common
infantrymen the Valyrian weapons seem
like they're destined for more greater
kills which just leads me to believe
that they'll be used on the white Walker
generals but let me know in the comments
Arya Stark filming most of her scenes
during these night battles do you think
that she is going to be the one to kill
all of these white Walker generals or do
you think that they're gonna let some of
the other characters wielding Valyrian
swords to take them down like Jon Snow
or Jaime Lannister Jaime Lannister
himself seems like he's more of a
general type figure so I'd be surprised
if he spends a lot of time charging the
field you dumb fool remember him
charging Drogo
they'll probably be some similar moment
during season eight but it'll be Brianne
yelling at him not Tyrion circling back
around to the dagger there are a lot of
theories about its prehistory on the TV
show a lot of people think that Rhaegar
may have reforged it from dark sister I
think the fact that it appears in Sam
walls book implies that it's much older
than that so I think that if Rhaegar
possessed this dagger at one point he
just bought the dagger rather than
having it forged brand-new just remember
there was a giant Ruby embedded in it in
Rhaegar himself had a fondness for
rubies his breastplate was covered in
them when Robert killed him at the
Trident is it rubies flew everywhere is
if his blood was flying everywhere so
there's just a lot of imagery tying
Rhaegar to the dagger and there's still
a lot of things that they could reveal
about his history during season eight
but I think for the most part a lot of
those Robert's rebellion flashbacks were
just to tell you who Jon Snow was
exactly oh this is a person that
actually has a claim for the Iron Throne
because he was a legitimate son of
Rhaegar and Lyanna you may have seen the
news recently about George our Martin
clarifying his book releases that are
coming up he did say fire and blood the
part one of the Targaryen family history
is supposed to come out later this year
he confirmed winds of winter definitely
not this year so 2019 at the earliest
which makes us is the final season of
the TV show so be good opportunity to
try and sync up that book release
there's a part two to fire in blood
that's a little further off but that
will probably drop after a winds of
winter then obviously dream of spring
will be so far off that it'll drop at
some point during the prequel series
because that's not supposed to premiere
till 2020
so if dream of spring takes as long as
wins a winter took to come out then
we'll get it before the end of the
prequel series but you know who knows
how long it's gonna take it's anybody's
guess at this point it's a really bad
idea to try and predict George are
Martin book release dates
congratulations to the latest DVD
giveaway winner Mike EXO 12 please
private message me so I can get your
contact details there was a new round on
this video all you have to do to enter
that is just be a subscriber or leave a
game of Thrones related comments on the
video click here to listen to the
producers tease Cersei scenes during
season 8 and click here for all my black
panther Easter eggs thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight